[Music]
it was here on the slopes of Mount Doom
that the Dark Lord Sauron was defeated
by a last alliance of men and elves it
is here that for two and a half thousand
years the Rangers of Gondor stood watch
guarding against a nameless threat had
all but forgotten
and while the strength of Gondor faded
the power and malice of Sauron grew in
darkness he has returned to Mordor
shadow and flame have fallen on the
Black Gate and no mortal man
can stand in its path
welcome to middle-earth shadow of Mordor
you are talent a fallen Ranger of Gondor
and a guardian of the black gates
murdered along with everyone you've ever
loved attacked by sirens black captain's
a mysterious elven Spirit has brought
you back from beyond the grave
initially the wraith remembers nothing
and relies on tallien to help him
discover his identity only you could
accomplish such bond Kaleb Rimbaud
greatest myth of the Second Age
I'd heard the stories but I remember my
name now I shape the history of
middle-earth I crafted the rings of
power as Killebrew noir learns more of
his past than his connection to the
Rings of Power they realized that all of
middle-earth will be doomed if they
cannot reach the Dark Lord caliber in
war enhances tally instead Lee's skills
and grants him the gift and curse to
cheat death but perhaps the most
powerful race skill is the ability to
enter the minds of his enemies to both
manipulate and terrify
up numbered and targeted by all Italian
and Kelly Birnbaum must work in unison
to learn of their true potential and
bring to justice those that have taken
everything from disgust we find one who
cast a toss
[Music]
talans ultimate goal is to get to ser on
Spock captain's bring me the head of
this grave Walker along the way tell Ian
will encounter friends and allies in the
most unexpected of places some
characters have valuable information
that will help telly and find answers
why have you returned you are not done
yet others will teach Italian methods
that will prove very useful on his
journeys torben a beast on top right bag
I'll tell you everything we're going to
find out why you know both familiar
faces and new allies are all at the
mercy of Saiyans war machine Italian
faces not only scores of depraved orcs
and their captains but also deadly
beasts and the black captains themselves
about
we bow to no one stand up and fight
rooms at powerful buffs Italians weapons
and are dropped as loot when enemy
captains are vanquished epic rooms are
rare and powerful upgrades that can make
talons weapons even more legendary
finding an epic rune requires talent of
dominate a captain and have him deliver
a death threat to his war chief hearing
Italian is after him
and it's promising a cruel death the war
chief surrounds himself with bodyguards
for protection long fight oh he's got a
daily god defeating the war chief and
his gang is no easy task but the reward
is great with a death threat fulfilled
the war chief Trump's an epic rune
through a variety of customizable rune
combinations and his weapons Italian
will become a legend and brandish an
arsenal without equal in all of Mordor
can teach you the ways of the orc that
can make your plan work
the Nemesis system populates Mordor with
dynamic and personal enemies
we'll remember each interaction with
tallien already bought at every work has
their own unique tendencies from cunning
from dissecting your calls to weak and
easily spooked all works are looking to
make a name for themselves gain power
and rise in rank higher and get quick
work society is based on a military
hierarchy powerful war Chiefs rule
strongholds while their merciless
captain's do the dirty work
any Oracle manages to kill Italian will
be immediately promoted and celebrated
promotions are also granted upon
successful completion of missions such
as beast hunts feasts and recruitment
missions are you ready to join a real
army maggots by using the powers of the
Wraith tallien can cause power struggles
that disrupt surrounds army by
dominating branding powerful captain's
Italian can amass his own orc army
behind enemy lines
Ranger oh now that's what I call
teamwork
the harsh and unforgiving land of Mordor
is not only populated by vindictive
works but is also home to terrifying
beasts of various sizes some too big and
dangerous to ignore first lesson of
category on Titan do not die Italian
must learn to harness the powers of
these ferocious beasts eventually
gaining the ability to dominate and bend
them too as well
cops let's go spill something hey when
you preorder middle or a shadow of
Mordor you'll receive the dark Ranger
character skin along with a test of
power challenge mode in this time to
challenge mode you must completely
annihilate a hit list of work captain's
and war Chiefs after we killed your
woman get a head start on upgrades with
runes drop during the challenge and earn
a place of top of leaderboards see if
you can become the bane of all works I
supposed to be scared the season pass
includes the exclusive guardians of the
flaming I a war band of Saiyans elite
defenders early access to the trials of
war challenge modes as well as the Lord
of the hunt expansion which includes new
enemies and hours of gameplay and the
bright Lord expansion lets you continue
the epic story SK labrum bore himself
why do it cease these dreams they offer
no answers only more questions are not
experienced sufficient my power costs
stronger my power gives the Gateway to
defeating the dark lord do not seek
vengeance this system means an original
one force to eat
[Music]
you